main findings of this paper were that
women aged 50 to 59 who had had their
uterus removed a hysterectomy that among
those women not using estrogen had led
to an excess mortality and the excess
mortality adds up if you consider the
total population which is what we did it
adds up to almost 50,000 women prior to
200 to 90 percent of women who had no
uterus remember we're talking very
specifically now about women who have no
uterus who are in their 50s and prior to
200 to 90 percent of those women would
have used estrogen therapy for at least
five years today the figure is less than
10% knowing about that decline in the
use of estrogen allowed us to make
several different calculations using all
of the assumptions the best point
estimates are between forty two thousand
two hundred and forty eight thousand
eight hundred women have died in the
last ten years between 200 to two eleven
none of those women lived to be 70 years
old they were all women at the beginning
of the period aged 50 to 59 who would
have used that sturgeon in the past but
did not use it because of fear of taking
estrogen which was unfounded in the past
90% of those women would have been using
estrogen replacement and today the
percent is less than 10% what has
happened has been an avoidance of the
use of estrogen because not of the
findings of the Women's Health
Initiative but the way in which they
will communicate it and understood and
that's the reason for our paper has
helped to promote a better understanding
of what are the beneficial effects not
just what are the detrimental effects of
hormones there